Everyone and their dog know about Russian
scientist Ivan Pavlov and, well, his dog,
and how he trained him to drool on command
at the sounding of a bell.
His discovery of conditioned reflexes won
him a Nobel Prize in Psychology.
Pretty straightforward, right?
Wrong!
Much of what we know about Pavlov’s experiment
has been misrepresented and mistranslated,
so join me in today’s Biographics to learn
the truth behind Ivan Pavlov’s research
and his fascinating life.
A word of warning: if you happen to watch
these videos with your canine friends, this
is one where you may want to cover their ears…
A Boy’s Favourite Uncle
Ivan Petrovich Pavlov was born in Ryazan,
in the Russian Empire, about 200 miles from
Moscow on the September 26, 1849.
Ivan’s father, Petr, was the local Orthodox
Parish priest, a well-liked and respected
figure who supplemented the family’s income
by growing his own vegetables and brewing
his own vodka-based fruity liquor.
Ivan was a frail and sickly child, one you
might immediately assign to the role of bookworm.
Except that he had absolutely no power of
concentration, hated reading and had a pretty
volatile temper.
In fact, he avoided homework as often as he
could, preferring to help Petr in tending
to his plot of land.
At the age of eight, Ivan suffered a bad fall,
plunging from a tall fence onto a stone slab.
As he struggled to recover from his injuries,
his godfather, also a priest, stepped in.
For some reason, he believed that what the
boy needed was not a proper trauma assessment
or a doctor, but
“Discipline, discipline and more discipline”
So he took Ivan to his monastery, where for
several months the boy lived like a monk.
The therapy did produce some results; bored
out of his mind, Ivan started doing something
he had never considered: reading!
With little other recourse, the young boy
learned to enjoy it, devouring the monastery’s
library.
When he returned home, his personality had
changed.
He was calmer, more focused, and had a great
desire to learn.
Petr reignite his hopes of sending Ivan to
seminary to become a new addition to the Pavlov
Family’s roster of clergymen.
The other pivotal moment in young Ivan’s
life was when his uncle -- also a priest,
also named Ivan -- moved in with the family.
If Petr wanted to provide his son with strong
role models, he had done a rubbish job, as
Uncle Ivan was a terrible priest.
Shortly after he was assigned his most recent
church, local parishioners had started reporting
ghastly sightings of a white, robed figure
stalking the graveyard.
Bodies were dug out from their tombs and simply
disappeared.
The church bells had the habit of going off
at the most ungodly hours of the night.
Of course, it was all thanks to Uncle Ivan,
who enjoyed playing a prank or two while drunk
like a baboon at a bachelor party.
When the parishioners found out, they cornered
Uncle Ivan, thrashed him like a snare drum
at a Napalm Death recording session and kicked
him out of the village.
Uncle Ivan’s only choice was to move in
with his brother Petr, where apparently he
sobered up and developed a strong bond with
little Ivan.
The boy loved the elder Ivan, from whom he
heard stories about his other uncle -- also
a priest, also named Ivan.
Because why choose new names when you can
confuse amateur historians instead?!
Now, about Uncle Ivan II.
Was he a good priest?
Not really.
His favourite past-time was a sort of brawling
much in fashion during those days.
Basically, the men of one street, or an entire
village, would fill up on enough vodka to
floor a company of Varangians, then challenged
a rival team of equally intoxicated sluggers.
Think of it as a Russian donnybrook.
Now, I don’t know about you, but my local
priest only drank weak tea and a glass of
port on Christmas Day, and he only challenged
the village postman at chequers.
Anyhow, Uncle Ivan II once took his brawl
too far, and he died as a result of his injuries.
I am not sure if such role models would encourage
a young mind to take up priesthood, but these
experiences surely taught a vital lesson to
young Ivan: the importance of moderation and
the avoidance of all excesses in life.
With a strong moral compass installed by the
tales of his elder Ivans, Pavlov was finally
sent to study at a seminary.
His experience at the religious school started
promisingly, but soon Ivan was distracted
by the irresistible allure of a demanding
mistress: science.
During the early 1860s, Russian society had
initiated a period of economic, social, and
cultural reforms promoted by Tsar Alexander
II, who ascended to the throne in 1855.
Most notable was the abolition of serfdom,
which totally revolutionized the Russian economy.
Another key element of these reforms was the
promotion of science to foster modernisation
of the State.
As a result, local public libraries were stocked
with scientific works by both Russian and
foreign author previously unavailable.
Ryazan’s public library was flooded by Ivan
and his friends, who had formed a discussion
circle to review and analyse modern scientific
discussions.
Works like Charles Darwin’s The Origin of
the Species or the journals by radical scientist
Dmitry Pisarev.
One book would be particularly relevant in
Ivan’s future career: Reflexes of the Brain
by Ivan Sechenov, in which the author argued
that all human behaviours and thoughts could
be explained as a result of machine-like reflexes
and reactions.
Young Ivan’s thirst for knowledge was so
avid that he would not allow any obstacle
to come in his way.
If the seminary demanded that he studied all
day, he would read at night or very early
in the morning.
When access to the library became so crowded
that fistfights exploded regularly, he convinced
a librarian to keep a window always open at
the back – so that he could climb into a
reading room undisturbed and get on with his
extra-curricular studies.
One of the Karamazovs?
In 1869, Ivan could no longer continue his
ruse of progressing his religious and scientific
studies along parallel tracks.
He had to let go of something, and that something
was religion.
He quit the seminary and enrolled at the University
of St. Petersburg to study chemistry and physiology
– the branch of biology that deals with
the normal functions of living organisms and
their parts.
Petr Pavlov was not pleased with this decision,
but Ivan had put his foot down.
He would stand by his rational choices, regardless
if these would sour his personal relationships.
In a later letter to his future wife, Ivan
compared himself to one of the Brothers Karamazov,
from the novel by Fedor Dostoyevsky: one of
the brothers, also named Ivan, was a rationalist
and an extreme skeptic, condemned to social
isolation for his nihilism.
By 1875, Ivan had earned a degree and a doctorate
from the Imperial Medical Academy, and continued
his studies under renowned physiologists Rudolf
Heidenhain and Carl Ludwig.
At the same time, he had enrolled at the Academy
of Medical Surgery, where in 1879 he attained
his third degree and was awarded a gold medal
for academic results.
Ivan’s studies were crowned by his doctor’s
thesis, published in 1883.
Its title was
“The Centrifugal Nerves of the Heart”
Which sounds like a bad Bonnie Tyler outtake,
but was actually a pioneering work in which
he laid down the basic principles of the trophic
function of the nervous system.
In other words: the role of the nervous system
in nutrition.
In the meanwhile, Ivan had married a teacher
called Seraphima Karchevskaya, also known
as Sara, in 1881.
Their first years together were not happy.
Initially, the couple lived in almost complete
poverty, while Ivan was still perfecting his
studies.
They had to frequently crash at friends’s
houses or rent bug-infested attics.
Tragically, Sara’s first pregnancy ended
in a miscarriage; according to the doctors
of the time, this was caused by Sara’s constant
attempts to keep up with Ivan, a very fast
walker.
It seems more likely that the couple’s unhealthy
living conditions played a role.
Ivan and Sara soon tried to have another child,
and Wirchik was born shortly afterward.
Unfortunately, the baby boy died suddenly
while still an infant.
Despite their grief, the couple’s life improved
in the following years.
In 1890, Ivan received a series of appointments
which improved their financial situation.
He was first invited to direct the Department
of Physiology at the Institute of Experimental
Medicine, a post he would hold for the next
45 years; then, he was hired by the Military
Medical Academy, first as Professor of Pharmacology,
then as Chair of Physiology.
All that hard work and study had eventually
paid off.
Ivan and Sara were also blessed with four
healthy children, Vladimir, Victor, Vsevolod
and Vera.
With his professional and personal life on
track, Ivan Pavlov launched into the research
that really mattered to him, the one on the
physiology of digestion.
This took place at the Institute of Experimental
Medicine, from 1891 to 1900, and would make
him a household name.
[Note to Simon: this could be a natural point
to insert the sponsor message.
E.g.
“But before we look at Pavlov’s brilliant
hands on approach to science, how about you
take a hands-on approach to knowledge with
Brilliant?”
– assuming that’s the sponsor.
Or
“Unlike Ivan, you don’t need nine years
to find out about how the digestive system
works, in fact 15 minutes would be enough.
Try Blinkist etc etc” if that’s the sponsor.
Or:
“Before we get into Ivan’s experiments
on dogs, let me tell you what I feel like
doing to people who harm dogs.
That’s right: shoot them with
a tank!
And you know where you can practice with a
tank?
That’s right, War Thunder!”.
If that’s the unlikely sponsor]
A man’s best friend,
a dog’s worst enemy
OK, back to Ivan Pavlov and his experiments.
First, let’s cover his methodology.
It may sound commonplace today that science
should be grounded on data produced via experimentation,
but when Pavlov emerged as a notable scientist,
this wasn’t necessarily a given when it
came to physiology.
Pavlov was the first physiologist in the Russian
Empire to devote himself to repeated experimentation,
applying a factory-like approach to his lab.
Pavlov recognised that meaningful changes
in the normal functions of a living organism
could be assessed only over time.
Pavlov’s contemporaries would experiment
on an animal, then discard it, or even kill
it once the experiment was done.
Pavlov instead preferred to keep his animals
alive -- especially dogs -- in order to document
physiological changes over a longer time span.
He referred to this method as “chronic experiments”.
And this is the moment when you may want to
cover your dog’s ears, or send them playing
somewhere else.
If Pavlov’s lab was a factory, then the
dogs were his machines.
He performed surgical operations on every
test subject, opening a ‘fistula’ along
their digestive traits.
A fistula is an opening in a living organism
which allows one to observe the inner workings
of its organs.
Pavlov needed these fistulas opened for two
reasons: 1) to observe the functioning of
his dogs’ digestive functions, in particular
the production of gastric juices; and 2) to
collect said secretions.
So, yeah, Ivan Pavlov may have not systematically
killed his lab animals, but their treatment
wasn’t a walk in the park – which I suppose
is what they were probably hoping for, considering
they were dogs.
It was a treatment that was painful, at best,
and caused the death of the subjects at worst.
Particularly in his early experiments, Pavlov
was constantly stymied by the difficulty of
keeping his subjects alive after operating
on them.
Even if one of his ‘machines’ tragically
died, Ivan was always ready to replace them.
But what exactly did this factory, or lab,
produced?
Pavlov and his team cranked out scientific
papers on the physiology of the digestive
system, new research techniques, and an important
by-product: gastric juice – litres of it.
Ivan Pavlov was always strapped for research
cash and he had stumbled upon a lucrative
side gig: Russian patients suffering from
dyspepsia were ready to pay good money for
canine gastric juice, considered an effective
treatment at that time.
Dyspepsia is more commonly referred to as
‘indigestion’ and includes symptoms such
as bloating, discomfort, nausea.
So yeah, if you are feeling nauseous and bloated,
what better remedy than gulping down a nice
glass of warm, thick, moist, pungent gastric
juice freshly harvested from a fistulated
drooling dog?!?
Can you give me a minute, I think I am going
to be si-
[Editing note: screen cuts abruptly to black,
with a short burst of static noise.
The camera then returns to Simon, who continues
as if nothing had happened]
Pavlov had the perfect set up for his indigestion
medicine factory: five large young dogs, selected
for their voracious appetites, were harnessed
on a long table.
Each dog was subjected to an incision of the
oesophagus: this opened a fistula, from which
a tube led to the collection vessel.
Each of these dogs faced a stand, tilted to
display a large bowl of minced meat, just
out of reach.
This stimulated the production of saliva and
gastric juices.
By 1904, Pavlov’s side gig was selling more
than three thousand flagons of dog gastric
juice per year, raking in profits that would
increase his lab budget by 70 percent.
The Experiment
Besides capitalising on his own brand of furry
Taylorism, Pavlov began his research of what
he called “psychic secretions” – which
sounds like something Dr Stantz or Dr Spengler
may want to analyse, too.
But in simple terms, psychic secretions were
drool produced by anything other than direct
exposure to food.
And here we get to Pavlov’s famous experiments.
Just to clarify – it wasn’t a single occurrence
in which he rang a bell to get a dog to salivate,
as sometimes thought by modern popular culture,
but a ‘chronic experiment’ in line with
his scientific doctrine.
This is how it worked.
Pavlov’s main research was meant to study
the salivation of dogs in response to being
fed.
However, he soon noticed that the dogs would
begin salivating when they heard the footsteps
of the assistant bringing their food.
Pavlov’s hypothesis was that any object
or event which the dogs learned to associate
with food would trigger the same response
as the food itself.
He started from the idea that dogs – or
other complex organisms – were hard-wired
to respond instinctively to certain stimuli.
In other words: an ‘unconditioned stimulus’,
for example: food, will elicit an ‘unconditioned
response,’ or salivation.
Dogs will salivate in the presence of food.
It’s not a behaviour they need to learn.
[Editing suggestion: introduce some graphics
to illustrate the various steps described
here:]
[Unconditioned Stimulus] -> [Unconditioned
response]
Pavlov then devised a series of experiments
to validate his initial hypothesis.
The first step was to introduce a neutral
stimulus: this could be a metronome or an
electric buzzer – which in a mistranslated
paper became the famous bell.
The neutral stimulus did not elicit any response.
[Neutral Stimulus] -> [No conditioned response]
Next, it was time to begin the conditioning
procedure, that is associating the neutral
stimulus with the unconditioned stimulus.
In this example: introducing a clicking metronome
before the dog chow was served.
Finally, Pavlov played the metronome, but
failed to produce the food.
I am sure the dogs were dead disappointed,
but what mattered to the scientist is that
the clicking in itself … did increase the
drooling!
So now a conditioned stimulus had elicited
a conditioned response, also described as
‘conditional’ response in some translations
from the original Russian articles.
[Conditioned Stimulus] -> [Conditioned response]
Pavlov’s experiments would become more sophisticated:
for example, he tried playing around with
specific metronome speeds, like serving food
only when it clicked at sixty beats per minute.
Over time, his dogs became so specifically
conditioned that they failed to salivate at
any other setting.
Pavlov began to deduce that there were colliding
forces of “excitation” and “inhibition”
at play.
At first, a stimulus may spread broadly across
the cerebral cortex, or the area of the brain
responsible for processing inputs and maintaining
cognitive functions.
Later, in a potential second phase of selective
reinforcement, the stimulus could be concentrated
on one specific spot of the cortex.
I should reinforce here that Pavlov’s interest
was always grounded in physiology and in the
understanding of the digestive system.
However, his work did have a huge impact on
the field of psychology: Pavlov’s discoveries
pushed behavioural psychologists into developing
the concept of ‘classical conditioning’
also known as ‘Pavlovian conditioning’.
This is a process of learning by association,
which, according to behaviourists, can explain
all aspects of human psychology.
In the 1920s, psychologist John Watson went
as far as denying completely the existence
of the mind, or consciousness, believing that
individual behaviours, speech patterns, and
emotional responses are simply a consequence
of external stimuli which elicit certain responses
via classical conditioning.
Such an approach, taken to the extreme, negates
subjective experience.
In other words, ten different people, exposed
to the same input, would produce the same
output.
Interestingly, Pavlov never approved of the
theories that behaviourists had built on the
back of his experiments.
The Russian scientist firmly believed in the
importance of individuals in determining their
behaviour.
And while he, as a physiologist, did not have
the answers, he hoped science would one day
explain
“the mechanism and vital meaning of that
which most occupied Man—our consciousness
and its torments.”
Drooling over food, Spitting over the USSR
In 1903, at the 14th International Medical
Congress in Madrid, Pavlov read a paper on
«The Experimental Psychology and Psychopathology
of Animals».
His research was far from completed or exhaustive,
yet his findings took the scientific community
by storm.
He only had to wait one year before he was
awarded the Nobel Prize in Physiology or Medicine
"in recognition of his work on the physiology
of digestion, through which knowledge on vital
aspects of the subject has been transformed
and enlarged."
From then on, the laurels piled upon Ivan’s
head.
In 1907, he was elected Academician of the
Russian Academy of Sciences; in 1912, he was
given an honorary doctorate at Cambridge University;
in 1915, he was made a member of the French
Order of the Legion of Honour, following a
lobbying campaign by the Medical Academy of
Paris.
Which takes us just two years before a certain
event which shook the World …
When the October Revolution of 1917 ousted
Kerensky’s Government and Lenin rose to
power, Pavlov was sixty-eight and had been
a Nobel Laureate for 13 years.
He had had no particular sympathies for the
Tsarist regime, which had been notoriously
stingy when it came to funding research.
He wasn’t terribly fond of communism, either,
and would not hide his feelings about it.
Ivan Pavlov was always vocal in his opposition
to communism and its Russian incarnations.
He only had two words to spare for Karl Marx:
“That fool”
And he wasn’t any kinder to the leaders
of the Bolshevik Revolution.
And yet his international standing was unassailable,
and Ivan could get away with the most outspoken
and ferocious critiques of the regime.
Pavlov considered Communism a “doomed”
experiment that had turned Russia back into
a nation of serfs, and he saw Bolshevism as
a system of government that devalued culture
and the intellectual strength of a nation.
How did Lenin treat this rogue, but celebrated
scientist?
At first, Pavlov and his family were treated
like any other Soviet citizens, which means
many of their assets were confiscated as property
of the State, including the Nobel Prize money
… money that could have come in handy for
the tough times that lay ahead.
From 1917 to 1920, the revolutionary government
had to defend itself against the White Armies
in the Russian Civil War, a situation that
caused generalised famine and fuel shortages
for Russian citizens.
Like most residents of Petrograd, the Pavlovs
struggled to feed themselves and keep from
freezing, as at least a third of Pavlov’s
colleagues at the Academy of Sciences starved
or froze to death.
Pavlov barely struggled to keep his family
alive by growing potatoes and other vegetables
right outside his lab, and by collecting small
amounts of firewood from a colleague.
In 1920, Pavlov wrote to Lenin’s secretary,
seeking permission to emigrate to Western
Europe or America, in search of better living
conditions and more funding for his lab.
Lenin immediately realised the negative PR
repercussions of losing the country’s most
celebrated scientist.
He ordered Petrograd Party leaders to increase
rations for Pavlov and his family, and to
make sure his working conditions improved.
Ivan Pavlov had prevailed over Lenin thanks
to his prestige.
Would he have the same luck with his successor?
Josef Stalin started his climb to absolute
power after Lenin’s death in 1924, and by
1927 he had launched one of his many purges,
focused on intellectuals and scientists.
Pavlov was outraged, especially when restrictive
measures were aimed at Jewish scientists.
Now, in his private life, Pavlov was as anti-Semitic
as Stalin.
In his view, Trotsky was a
“vile yid”
And in 1928, Pavlov had complained to an American
colleague that
“Jews occupy high positions everywhere … it’s
a shame that the Russians cannot be rulers
of their own land.”
But it is undisputed that the scientist had
a strong sense of justice.
At a time when vocal dissent may land you
in a Gulag, or shot in the back of the head
by a secret police goon, Pavlov wrote to Stalin
complaining against the purge, saying that
he was
“ashamed to be called a Russian.”
We don’t know Stalin’s reaction to such
complaints, but we can speculate that he was
not amused.
Luckily for Pavlov, he could rely on powerful
allies: Nikolai Bukharin, chairman of the
Comintern’s executive committee, considered
Pavlov indispensable and defended his case
with Politburo members:
“I know that he does not sing the ‘Internationale,’
but despite all his grumbling, ideologically
(in his works, not in his speeches) he is
working for us.”
In a case of pragmatism triumphing over paranoia,
Stalin agreed with Bucharin and ensured the
Party would continue supporting Pavlov.
The scientist and his labs continued to prosper,
even in the years leading up to Stalin’s
Great Purge.
Pavlov expanded his operations to three laboratories,
staffed with hundreds of scientists and lab
assistants, and was even permitted to collaborate
with scholars in Europe and America.
But his relationship with the government was
never easy.
Apparently Moscow officials did not understand
why their Big Boss allowed Pavlov to
“Spit on the Soviets”
… as politburo member Valerian Kuibyshev
put it.
Kuibyshev, who was Chairman of the State Planning
Committee, and had influence over government
investment in agriculture, industry and science,
tried to oppose Pavlov as much as he could,
at least within the limits of what Stalin
allowed him to do.
This meant that Kuibyshev was forced anyways
to fund Pavlov’s laboratories, but had no
intention of ever honouring him.
When a proposal was floated to celebrate Pavlov’s
80th anniversary as an affair of State, Kuibyshev
put his foot down: no cake for him!!!
At least not sponsored by the State.
After all, couldn’t they just play him a
metronome or something?
That should do, right?
Legacy
For a while, Kuibyshev successfully prevented
excessive displays of admiration towards the
Nobel Laureate, but by 1934, the hostile official
had been removed from his post.
Because that’s how Stalin rolled.
A good occasion to publicly celebrate the
pride of Russian science arrived on the 27th
of February, 1936, although I am sure Pavlov
would have preferred to avoid it.
Why?
Well, this occasion was his death.
Ivan Pavlov worked in his laboratory until
the very end, even after contracting a double
pneumonia which eventually claimed his life.
The Soviet Government honoured the great scientist
by organising a grand funeral, at which a
hundred thousand mourners, including Party
officials, filed past his casket.
Ivan Petrovich Pavlov was a physiologist until
his very last day on Earth, and yet the impact
of his work was most felt in Psychology.
His methods may have not been the most ethical,
particularly when it came to our modern standards
surrounding matters like animal cruelty.
More broadly, the classical conditioning theories
he spawned, as well as behaviourist psychology
in general, were criticised by later generations
of psychologists for being too reductive.
Even Pavlov did not fully agree with strict
classical conditioning theory, as it did not
allow for the individual conscience to play
a role in human behaviour.
Pavlov’s true enduring legacy lies in the
use of a rigorous scientific method to prove
the existence of conditioned and non-conditioned
reflexes, which provided a foundation for
the study of acquired human behaviour and
the use of positive reinforcement in learning.